Hola Esto es África siete días en
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es man Y estos son los titulares
el presidente de Sudáfrica Siri la rama
Poza está en la cuerda floja un informe
parlamentario sobre un robo de dinero
oculto en un sofá en una de sus
propiedades ha levantado sospechas
tenemos los detalles en Liberia al
presidente George wea lleva ausente del
país desde finales del mes de octubre en
un contexto de su vida de precios y
escasez de productos de primera
necesidad sus viajes son mal percibidos
por la población y la oposición habla de
abandono de cargo la selección
senegalesa último equipo subsahariano en
competir en el mundial de Qatar ha sido
eliminada hablaremos de ello con Luis
Méndez periodista deportivo de France 24
comenzamos en Sudáfrica donde el jefe de
estado ciri la rama posa enfrenta una
fuerte polémica tras la publicación de
un informe que lo declara responsable de
violar la Constitución después de un
robo de varios cientos de miles de
dólares que estaban ocultos en el
interior de un sofá que se encontraba en
una de sus residencias rama posada está
acusado de malversación pero mantiene
respaldo de su partido Aquí les
explicamos En qué consiste el caso que
ha tenido en la mira al presidente
el presidente sudafricano civil rama
fosa enfrenta un escándalo desde hace
meses según las conclusiones de un
informe encargado de determinar si el
mandatario debe ser destituido los
hechos que le Son reprochados son
suficientemente graves
llevar al presidente a un procedimiento
de instituciones una decisión de Gran
envergadura que no puede tomarse sobre
bases frágiles tiene que haber algo
tangible a lo que se pueda aferrar antes
de tomar esa decisión
[Música]
los hechos se remontan a hace dos años
cuando unos ladrones irrumpieron en una
lujosa propiedad de Rama fosa los
bandidos encontraron bajo los cojines de
un sofá fajos de billetes por valor de
al menos 580 mil dólares y los robaron
se acusa al presidente de no haber
denunciado lo ocurrido ni a la policía
ni a las autoridades Fiscales lo que
constituye una violación de la
Constitución y de una ley anticorrupción
los juristas que redactaron el informe
creen que las sospecha sobre el origen
del dinero son bastante graves como para
cuestionar la del presidente el
parlamento promovió un juicio político
en su contra pero hasta la publicación
del informe rama fosa había conseguido
mantener las apariencias recientemente
de visita de estado en Londres el
mandatario se mostró relajado y restó
importancia al riesgo de destitución
qué opina de que este debate sigue
adelante le preocupa que este caso pueda
llevar a su destitución
no no creo que he dejado Claro mi punto
y por supuesto dejamos que el panel
llegue a un resultado no podemos
prejuzgar yo no puedo usted no puede y
lo tenemos que dejar en manos del panel
[Música]
la publicación del informe ha debilitado
no solo al presidente sudafricano sino
también a su partido y Congreso Nacional
africano que por ahora dice apoyarlo
pero que seguirá con la duda de si
cambiar o no
pasemos ahora a Sudán los líderes
militares y representantes civiles han
firmado un acuerdo para poner fin a la
crisis política en el país y avanzar
hacia una transición a la democracia con
un gobierno civil el pacto llega tras
múltiples intentos para desbloquear la
situación desde que el jefe del ejército
a abdo del borjan se hiciera con el
poder hace más de un año fue negociado
en presencia de funcionarios de la ONU
diplomáticos occidentales y
representantes de Arabia Saudita y
emiratos árabes Unidos sin embargo la
medida fue inmediatamente denunciada por
cientos de sudaneses que se reunieron en
la capital jartung
firmamos La retirada completa de los
militares del proceso político esto
debería ir acompañado de La retirada de
las fuerzas políticas del periodo de
transición en respuesta a las demandas
de los revolucionarios los militares
deben volver cuarteles mientras que los
partidos políticos deben avanzar hacia
las elecciones
estamos reunidos hoy aquí en el corazón
de la Revolución sudanesa los
manifestantes sudaneses son los
verdaderos actores del cambio la firma
del acuerdo no refleja Las verdaderas
fuerzas revolucionarias que son los
verdaderos actores de cualquier cambio
continuamos nuestro recorrido de la
actualidad africana en Liberia donde la
agenda del presidente
provoca polémica su asistencia a un
evento internacional tras otro y ahora
una pasada por el mundial de
Qatar donde su hijo juega con Estados
Unidos El mandatario lleva casi 50 días
o fuera la oposición lo acusa de dejar
el país en piloto automático
cuando George wea presidente de Liberia
abandonó su país a finales de octubre
sus compatriotas no imaginaban que no
volverían a ver a su presidente en más
de 40 días las obligaciones diplomáticas
pero también Algún capricho personal lo
han mantenido en un viaje prolongado que
la mayoría de los liberianos ahogados
por la inflación y la escasez que
atraviesa el país ven con malos ojos
estoy en contra del tiempo que el
presidente está pasando fuera del país
sobre todo con las circunstancias en las
que estamos las razones muy sencilla fue
elegido para servir a la nación y además
nos encontramos en un momento crucial en
el que nos dirigimos hacia elecciones
nacionales
en las últimas semanas el presidente ha
participado en un foro sobre el diálogo
norte sur en Marruecos en la conferencia
sobre el clima en Egipto en un foro
sobre cooperación internacional en
Francia en otros sobre deporte y paz en
Mónaco y una cumbre de líderes africanos
en Estados Unidos en medio de esta
agenda pasó 10 días en la Copa del Mundo
donde su hijo defendía los colores de
Estados Unidos la oposición aprovechó
esta prolongada ausencia y la denunció
como un abandono del cargo pero en las
calles de la capital Monrovia el
presidente sigue contando con cierto
apoyo
no tengo ningún problema con los actos a
los que asistió el hecho de que fuera el
nombre del país creo que es necesario
la polémica sin embargo está suscitando
un creciente nerviosismo en el país de
Cara a las elecciones que se celebrarán
en 2023
pasemos ahora a la actualidad deportiva
senegal la última selección subsahariana
en competir en el mundial cayó eliminada
tres por cero ante Inglaterra está con
nosotros en el estudio Luis Méndez
periodista deportivo de France 24 Luis
bienvenido África siete días Muchas
gracias Luis quería hablar de la derrota
de los leones de la taranga era el
seleccionado inglés superior al africano
voy a hablar de que era superior al
africano sino que cuentan con más
experiencia este conjunto de Inglaterra
tiene un arduo trabajo que viene por más
de diez años trabajando juntos también
en categorías menores y sobre todo eso
influye a la hora de jugar este tipo de
partidos como lo es un octavos de final
en una copa del mundo por eso es que es
importante determinar que la selección
de senegal hizo un gran trabajo al
enfrentar a Inglaterra porque por
momentos presionó e incluso llegó a
tener oportunidades de anotar un gol
Lamentablemente para los senegaleses se
atravesó Víctor el Arquero inglés y pudo
detener estas oportunidades que se le
crearon Al conjunto africano pero en
líneas generales creo que fue una grata
actuación la que dejó senegal en esta
Copa del Mundo mejora respecto a lo que
había hecho en el Rusia Hace cuatro años
que si bien logró acumular cuatro puntos
no pudo avanzar a los octavos de final y
esta vez en un grupo bastante complicado
pudo hacer así y esto se vio reflejado
también en senegal porque hay resultados
optimistas de Cara a lo que puede ser el
futuro de esta selección Y eso lo
podemos ver en el trabajo de nuestra
corresponsal en ese país
estoy excepcionado esperaba que senegal
ganara este partido y llegará a cuartos
de finales
no es demasiado doloroso porque
Inglaterra Tiene un gran equipo de
fútbol Así es la ley del deporte puedes
ganar siempre y de repente un día llega
otro equipo y te derrota
en el fútbol se gana o se pierde
mantendremos el ánimo la próxima vez
venceremos
y todos los equipos del África
subsahariana han sido eliminados de este
mundial porque es tan difícil que estos
equipos lleguen a cuartos de final hoy
en día podría hablarte de que todo pasa
por un tema mental saber disputar este
tipo de partidos que son de eliminación
directa
mantener la concentración durante 90
minutos porque el talento de los equipos
africanos hoy en día está hay que
recordar que muchos de estos jugadores
están en las mejores ligas de Europa
también participan en los mejores
torneos de Europa estamos hablando de
Champions League también de Europa
League o la Conference League también la
última liga que se creó Y esto es un
roce importante que están teniendo los
equipos africanos en este caso para
poder disputar este tipo de competencias
lo que hay que tomar en cuenta de cara
al futuro es mejorar estos aspectos
mantener la concentración a lo largo de
90 minutos y así poco a poco con la
trayectoria que están teniendo estos
jugadores pueden llegar a ese partido de
cuartos de final han transcurrido 20
años desde Italia 90 a Sudáfrica 2010 en
que dos selecciones africanas estuvieron
en cuartos de final yo creo que no vamos
a esperar otros 20 años para poder ver a
un equipo africano disputando esos
cuartos de final Y por qué no final o
una final de una copa del mundo pero a
mal quiero decirte que las cosas pintan
muy bien de cara al futuro de África si
nos ponemos evaluar hoy en día las tres
secciones de
subsaharianas tienen entrenadores que
son nacidos en esos países fueron
exjugadores que ya tomaron las riendas
de los combinados nacionales y por
supuesto que esto va a verse reflejado
en el futuro de cada selección porque
conocen la cultura conocen la manera de
jugar de cada uno de estos jugadores y
que por supuesto van a explotarlo al
máximo de Cara a lo que se viene en el
proceso eliminatorio para el mundial de
2026 y más adelante también ya en la
Copa del Mundo Luis Muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en África siete días
un placer terminamos esta edición con la
semana de la moda de Dakar que celebra
su aniversario número 20 en la histórica
isla senegalesa de gore más de
diseñadores de varios países africanos
han respondido al llamado a presentar
sus colecciones los dejamos con las
imágenes de los desfiles gracias por su
sintonía la actualidad sigue en France
24 y Francia 24.com